автомобільна парковка білизну описав bc
донецьку в особисто 9 церкві тут знати до
спав ахнула пізніше о другій годині а інші
роки не 25 чол їм ночі спеціальної
моніторингової місії я зафіксувала я
тільки активу кпс е
курячим паркуванням перед резиденцією bc у
цієї нудьги перетрі видно пожежників і
жарт відра ягу вали і намахалися
приборка від його воїнів я kno вершків
чотири автомобілі місії буму знаєш про
нових ним чи разом були знищені
вогнем з постеру качі пропускає
машини підпалили нам з але за у c
інцидент ви на плані з ставків то
свою роботу в донецьку та донецькій області
адже вони самі встануть на топпер
ми не плануємо прийняти свою роботу
випадково живі мопсики заходимо щоб
захочете ти своїх спіру битники
і ми закладка йому про б дві сторони треба
ти нам доступ долині зид до мене
щоб йому ви з прийняттям з постригати
потім якуніну потрібно досягнутих
домовленостей light cyan
раніше в донецькій області розпрощалися та
протести проти діяльності спеціальної
моніторингової місії обсі пришита до
адже булат 6 церкви в донецьку
або офісу обсі розлив і червону фарба я
камала б символ зубчастий дах учасника
акції знову тіла з ліжка гачів він
Ви об'єктивному світлані конфлікту на
донбасі пісні she's шкірою мітинги буксе
і в луганську копірайту хліб із суміші я
вислала ось танець оскільки ватою з
демонстрантами
аличу пропозицію не прийняв і група
людей до частини у демонстрації вигляд
молодість пилку в тис без посередників
нами кивай китами тонн праєш про
pitfall автомобілі фабрисіо донецьку вмс
україни розтягнули x пробуй соляка ти
врятувати лігачів таку атаку можу
організувати групи затікав і під час вибуху
мінських думала настей поважай експерт
одна з ми вірних припущені рахунку
атака задумі волосся все по трьом від
побудовані чого bsm подали вигляд лінії зид
мене музика їм ще мати йому слові степу
2 ст і bleach диво її башкаус броня
я що це привчання підтвердиться то це
можна свічки тієї про підготовку з
апарати вустами
наступав
ефекту від не відразу брат подобається
процес зі створення із зустрічі до Мінська
учасники тристоронньої контактної
групи сиру ваня конфлікту на донбасі
Натуся зайду молодості щось вид воду
зброї не їж лосів розбою калібру менше
сто міліметрів
представники україни Росії
самопроголошених республік
а так вже по-старому виду боячись і плану
і знову забрати з на прикиньте сир пням